well i'm starting today with brand new
allegations of even more criminality by
the trump crime family call them what
you want this doesn't even have to do
with anything allegedly done during the
administration this has to do with the
last couple of months yesterday
congresswoman liz cheney during another
installment of the january 6 trump riot
committee hearings announced that donald
trump has recently attempted to call a
forthcoming witness to try to intimidate
them presumably and that this has been
referred to the department of justice if
this is true and did trump leave a
voicemail we don't know the details yet
we will get to that if this is true
this is new alleged criminality so let's
go through it axios reporting liz cheney
says trump attempted to reach out to
january sixth witness
she said yesterday that former president
trump personally called an unidentified
january sixth committee witness cheney
says the committee has referred the
matter to the department of justice
which has the power to prosecute the
former president
if it determines he tampered with a
congressional witness let's take a look
at the video this is absolutely stunning
stunning stuff
and one more item after our last hearing
president trump
tried to call a witness in our
investigation
a witness you have not yet seen in these
hearings
that person declined to answer or
respond to president trump's call
and instead alerted their lawyer to the
call
their lawyer alerted us
and this committee has supplied that
information to the department of justice
let me say one more time
we will take any effort to influence
witness testimony very seriously
thank you mr chairman i yield back
so the question of course is did donald
trump leave a voicemail because
attempted to call
the target of the call
didn't take the call
if you just have a missed call it could
be argued it was someone using trump's
phone how did you know it was really
trump how did you know there was going
to be an attempt to tamper with the
witness if trump was dumb enough to
leave a voicemail and we don't know the
answer to that that becomes a very
different story now there's been a
number of you emailed me and said
is it witness tampering if they never
actually speak to the witness well with
bribery attempting a bribe even if the
bribe is rejected is still a crime
this is sort of less clear and i looked
at different legal opinions on it and
it
there are many who say it's a crime
merely to attempt the tampering the
question is
how can you prove there was an attempt
we just don't know whether there's a
voicemail or not now this would be
shocking
if it weren't so predictable and it's
important to restate that this is also a
witness that has not been part of the
hearings yet this is presumably a
forthcoming witness and for trump to
personally call them suggested someone
very very close to trump now speculation
is could it be one of his own kids in
which case well we pro i mean i don't
know maybe he's maybe he doesn't speak
to his kids very often but maybe he does
uh jason campbell on twitter
called the waning weeks of the trump
administration
a shockingly incompetent empire of
criminality and if indeed the allegation
here is true that trump personally
called to try to tamper with the witness
and by tamper we mean influence the
testimony of that's really what we're
talking about the sort of mob boss
tactics of listen uh i know that you're
going to
do the right thing
and remain loyal because you're just
that type of person right this is these
are the mafia tactics that liz cheney
has previously said have been part of
the mo
of the former trump administration
during the january six committee
hearings and then the the last thing is
and of course we people are innocent
until proven guilty there's no question
of that in the legal system people are
innocent until proven guilty but in the
court of public opinion this program
operates in the court of public opinion
not in the in a legal court
it is not the behavior of innocent
people
and people with a free clear and
innocent mind
to call witnesses to try to influence
their testimony if you believe
if you know you did nothing wrong
then you don't really have anything to
worry about now you can say well maybe
you're worried that the witness will lie
and incriminate you well that would be
perjury that would be a crime
so um
stunning
shocking in a sense but all together
very predictable as many of you know i'm
a busy person i don't always have the
exact correct nutritional plan for my
meals every single day and that's why i
also take a multivitamin and a couple of
supplements but doing them all
separately can be a little bit time
consuming which is why athletic greens
is just fantastic and they're one of our
sponsors i've been using the athletic
greens since last year it just really
simplifies nutrition i just do a scoop
of the ag-1 and i'm getting 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals and my
probiotics and it's all from whole food
sources i drink it in the morning i know
i'm good i don't have to be messing
around with different pills and
supplements or whatever or spend time
planning it when what time of day do i
need to take each one i just get it all
with one scoop you can put it in a
smoothie you can drink it straight it
tastes great and then i'm just good for
the day it supports gut health and i'm
getting everything that i need and i'm
looking for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below